Guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend.
Hallo, ich heiße Fukambaran und bin auf dieser Station als Diensthabender.
Ich würde gerne mit dieses Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Zuerst werde ich ein paar Argumente fragen stellen.
Also, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Helena Berger.
Helena Berger.
H-E-L-E-N-A-B-E-E.
Genau, die schöne Helena.
Und Berger, B-E, wieder Berg, B-E-R-G-E-R.
Okay, und wie alt sind Sie, Frau Berger?
Ich bin 64.
64, und warum wurden Sie geborgen?
Am 12. Juni 59.
59, okay.
Und wie schwer sind Sie, oder wie viel wiegen Sie?
So 84 kg wiege ich.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,64 m.
Und haben Sie ein Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Ja, mein Hausarzt ist Dr. Winter.
Ja, Dr. Winter.
Okay.
Frau Berge, was hat Sie zu uns geführt?
Also, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, also, genau genommen hat der Dr. Winter gesagt,
wenn es mir wieder so schlecht geht, soll ich gleich in die Klinik gehen.
Und ja, jetzt fühle ich mich wieder so schlecht.
Ich habe das schon immer wieder, wenn ich die Treppe hoch laufe,
wenn ich mich ein bisschen anstrenge,
wenn ich die Treppe hochhebe,
wenn ich schwere Einkaufstasche habe,
oder so, puh, dass ich mit einmal keine Luft mehr bekomme.
Und dass ich so das Gefühl habe,
ich habe so ein Druckgefühl auf der Brust,
als ob da jemand drauf sitzt.
Und ja, das wird jetzt in den letzten Tagen immer schlimmer.
Mein Hausarzt ist im Urlaub.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Und ja.
Wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe,
haben Sie ein Luftnot und ein Gefühl.
Ja, ja.
Und das macht mir halt auch so ein bisschen Angst.
Jetzt will ich mich nur ein bisschen anstrengen.
Und das ist jetzt schon seit einer ganzen Weile so.
Aber heute Nachmittag ist es jetzt so schlimm geworden.
Ich habe ein bisschen aufgeräumt in meiner Wohnung.
Und habe ein bisschen Sachen hin und her geschoben.
Puh, dann habe ich mit einmal gemerkt,
geht nicht mehr, ne?
Entschuldigung Frau Abichmann.
Herr Okur, können Sie Ihre Mikrofon zu...
Vielen Dank.
Ja, wir können weiter machen.
Alles klar.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Bescheide, Frau Berger?
Ja, also das ist jetzt, dass es so unangenehm ist,
heute Nachmittag.
Deswegen bin ich dann auch gleich gekommen.
Ja, das ist eine gute Entscheidung.
Doktor Winter hat Sie zu uns überwiesen, oder?
Ja, der hat gesagt, wenn es wieder mal so schlecht ist,
soll ich gleich zu Ihnen gehen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie husten, oder?
Ja, morgens muss ich immer so husten, nach dem Ausstehen.
Und wenn Sie husten, kommt draus schleim, oder?
Nee, eigentlich ist das, da kommt gar nichts.
Nee, das kribbelt nur so ein bisschen im Hals.
Okay.
Sie haben mir gesagt, also diese Luftnot hat beim Strängung.
Also wenn Sie...
Bei Anstrengungen?
Bei Anstrengungen verschlechtert, oder?
Ja, da ist sie überhaupt aufgetreten, ja.
Normalerweise konnte ich ja immer alles so machen.
Aber jetzt, wenn ich schon eine Treppe hoch steige, merke ich,
muss ich ein bisschen husten.
Und ja, heute war es dann eben so, dass das richtig doll war,
dass ich so Gefühle hatte, überhaupt nicht gut Luft zu kriegen
und eben auch so diesen Druck auf der Brust zu haben.
Ist Ihnen Brustschmerzen aufgefallen, oder?
Ja, sag ich doch.
Ja, natürlich.
Diese Brustschmerzen sind heute Nachmittag aufgetreten, oder?
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Und jetzt sind die Schmerzen in anderen Körperregionen aus?
Nee, eigentlich ist es, also so richtig tüchtige Schmerzen sind es nicht.
Es ist mehr so ein Druckgefühl, so ein Engelgefühl.
Dass ich das Gefühl habe, ich kann nicht richtig durchatmen.
Okay.
Und Sie haben husten, trockene husten besonders morgen aufgetreten.
Ja, genau.
Es ist und okay, ich werde diese Gespräch und Unterbrechung,
mein Kollege werde ein EKG schreiben.
Wenn das ein EKG-Prozess ist, können wir weiter machen.
Okay, sehr gut.
Okay.
Und haben Sie noch etwas, haben Sie noch etwas bemerkt, also zum Beispiel
Sortbrennen, Aufstoßen, zum Beispiel?
Also schlapp fühle ich mich zurzeit schon, ja.
Und wenn ich aufstehe morgens, dann ist mir auch oft schwindelig,
wenn ich hoch komme, ja.
Muss ich mich erstmal auf die Bettkante setzen.
Und ja, nachts ist das besonders blöd, da habe ich das auch,
wenn ich nachts auf die Toilette muss.
Ja, dann muss ich auch, wenn ich aufwache, dann merke ich,
oh, jetzt muss aber zum Klo, ja.
Und dann muss ich aber erst auf der Bettkante sitzen,
damit mir, damit mir nicht schwindelig wird, ja.
Muss ich mich ein bisschen festhalten?
Ja, das ist nicht so eine gute Situation.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie ganz genau.
Und seit wann haben Sie diese Hustern?
Das ist noch nicht so lange, vielleicht so, ja, ich merke das jetzt
seit drei, vier Wochen so.
Drei, vier Wochen, okay.
Und sind Ihre Weine geschwollt?
Da sagen Sie überhaupt was, ja, meine neuen Sandalen, ja.
Merke ich, dass das da richtig so die Riemen sich abzeichnen, ja.
Die Beine und die Füße sind ein bisschen geschwollt zurzeit, ja.
Ich dachte, das kommt von der Wärme.
Die Beine füße geschwollten.
Ja.
Aber ich, ich, okay.
Okay.
Und sind Ihnen eine Überwärmung oder Schmerzen aufgefallen?
Den Füßen?
Nein.
Okay, okay.
Und leiden Sie an irgendwelche Herzerkrankungen?
Ja, also in meinem Alter, ne, ich habe ein bisschen hohem Blutdruck
und dann habe ich, habe ich bekannt, ein bisschen erlöhte Blutfeldwerte.
Ja, und, naja, das, aber sonst,
naja, gut, man hat mal gesagt, deswegen soll ich auch jetzt,
oder nehme ich auch Makumar.
Ich hatte wohl mal so Vorhoflemmern.
War noch, hat dann Sie Vorhoflemmern?
Ja, vor sechs Monaten war das mal, da war ich schon mal dann beim Arzt
und der hat mich dann auch in die Klinik geschickt
und dann hat man mir Makumar gegeben.
Okay, sehr gut.
Okay, Frau Werbe, ich wollte nur diese alle Informationen
an der Reihe aufschreiben, deswegen ich frage wieder.
Also Sie haben seit heute Nachmittag eine Luftnot und NG-Gefühl
mit Brustschmerzen.
Also Sie leiden unter trockenen Husten.
Sie sagen, dass Sie schlapp sind.
Ja, ich bin schlapp.
Und die beide Füße sind in Geschiwollung.
Geschiwollung ist ein bisschen aufgefallt.
Okay.
Und haben Sie einen Schornkostel, Schornhaltung,
oder wenn Sie die Bewege in den Schornkostel haben,
dann haben Sie diesen Schornkostel besser gemacht.
Also ich habe das Gefühl,
oder das Bedürfnis eigentlich, das Fenster aufzumachen
und so, dass ich Luft bekomme.
Das ist eine Sache.
Und ja, was ich schon auch mache,
dass ich Nachts mir jetzt zwei Kissen hole,
dann würde ich ein bisschen höher liegen in der Nacht.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Schlapp?
Also haben Sie eine Schlappprobleme?
Ja, davon abgesehen, dass ich eben Nachts mal zwischendurch auf die Toilette muss.
Da wache ich dann natürlich immer auf.
Und da ist es manchmal so, wenn ich mich dann wieder hinlege,
kann ich nicht sofort wieder einschlafen.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Der ist eigentlich ja immer noch ganz gut, ja.
Sie müssen, Sie müssen, Sie müssen, Sie müssen, Sie müssen,
Sie müssen in der Nacht zum Toilette geben, sagt uns um ja.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
So ein bisschen habe ich zugenommen, ja.
Aber nicht viel, also so zwei, drei Kilo habe ich zugenommen, ja.
Im Wercham.
Hab ich das nicht am Eis, was ich esse oder so,
an der Schokolade.
Im Wercham seid ihr auch, haben Sie zu genommen?
Ja, ich würde sagen so im letzten drei Monaten.
Und wie weit können Sie gehen oder laufen, ohne diese Beschwerden
oder diese Luftmord oder diese Brustschmerzen zu bekommen?
Also Treppe hoch, fängt schon nach einer Etage an, ja.
Aber wenn ich so gerade laufe, ich weiß nicht, wie viel sind das?
Da kann ich schon ein Stück laufen, Bergauf wird schon schwieriger, ja.
Und schnell kann ich natürlich auch nicht laufen.
Ja, ich verstehe hier Sie.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Fieber oder Übelkeit bemerkt?
Nee, also Fieber habe ich überhaupt. Die Idee bin ich gar nicht gekommen, mich zu messen.
Nein, nein.
Und Übel, richtig Übel ist mir nicht.
Also ich fühle mich schlapp, aber mir ist nicht schlecht, also nicht so vermagend herschlecht.
Und wie verhalten sich diese Beschwerden,
wenn bei der Hochlage der Spines oder ihre Spines, also geht es besser oder?
Also sie mal nachts.
Wenn sie flach liegen, fühlen Sie sich besser oder?
Ganz flach liegen kann ich nicht gut.
Wie gesagt, ich nehme die Kissen zu lachen, ne?
Und schlafen.
Okay.
Und Sie haben eine Art der Bruthochdruck, erhöhte Brutfettwerte.
Und Sie haben ein Anfohrofilme gelitten.
Wie gibt es das momentan etwas?
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen oder chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, aber ich meine das schon lange her.
Gott sei Dank ist das schnell vorbeigegangen.
Wo sieben Jahren hatte ich mal, das war schmerzhaft,
eine Entzündung von der Bauchspeicheldruse.
Okay.
Vor sieben Jahren, oder?
Ja, das ist jetzt sieben Jahre her, genau.
Okay.
Und seit wann haben Sie Bruthochdruck und erhöhte Brutfettwerte?
Wahrscheinlich schon zehn Jahre, ich weiß es gar nicht so genau.
Okay.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert oder stationär behandelt?
Frau Berger?
Ja, vor zehn Jahren habe ich recht zum neues Knie bekommen.
Also eine endoprothese haben Sie, oder?
Ja, genau.
Prothese.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente,
die ich mir jetzt ein, außer Hartmar.
Ja, ich nehme noch, ich nehme noch, ja, ich habe eine ganze Zettel hier.
Also ich nehme noch Atua-Vastatin.
20.
Dann nehme ich eine am Abend.
Dann nehme ich Bisoprol, eine am Morgen.
Dann nehme ich HCT, eine morgens.
Und Lisinoprilzehn nehme ich eine morgens.
Zum Frühstück gibt es immer schon richtig viel.
Und wie viel Milligramm diese Medikamente?
Wie viele Milligramm nehmen Sie diese Medikamente?
Marcoma, Bisoprolol, Hydrochlorotiasin.
Marcoma nehme ich immer so eine halbe morgens.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das für welche sind.
Ob es da verschiedene gibt.
Und dann Bisoprolol, 5.
HCT, 12,5.
Lisinoprilzehn.
Und Atua-Vastatin, 20.
Okay.
Und Frau Berge, sind Sie gegen Corona und Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Gegen Corona auf alle Fälle, gegen Kinderkrankheiten.
Also früher hat man das ja alles schön gemacht.
Ich glaube, wir haben alle Impfungen bekommen.
Und ja, dann ich habe als Hausmeisterin gearbeitet.
Und weil man da auch manchmal so im Garten sich verletzt hat,
habe ich auch zwischendurch mal eine Tätternussimpfung bekommen.
Das weiß ich noch.
Okay.
Und waren Sie in den letzten 6 Monaten im Ausland?
Im Ausland?
Nee, das kann ich mir gar nicht leisten.
Ich habe nicht so viel Geld, dass ich Urlaub machen kann.
Okay.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche Unverträglichkeiten oder Allergien?
Ja, was ich nicht vertragen kann.
Also ich habe so eine Hausstauballergie.
Da kriege ich halt Schnupfen und Niesen und Augen tränen und so.
Also muss ich immer gut sauber machen.
Und dann hat man mal festgestellt,
dass ich auf ein Antibiotikum, wie heißt das, das heißt Amoxicillin.
Das kann ich nicht vertragen.
Wie reagieren Sie sich, wenn Sie ein Amoxicillin eingenommen haben?
Oh, da kriege ich so einen juckenden Ausschlag.
Okay.
Und Frau Berger, rauchen Sie?
Oh, seit 6 Jahren habe ich aufgehört mit dem Rauchen.
Ja, aber davor habe ich viele Jahre so ein bisschen geraucht.
Also ein halbes Päckchen am Tag, so 10 Kippen am Tag habe ich geraucht.
10 Zigaretten am Tag haben Sie geraucht.
Das ist sehr gut für Ihre Gesundheit.
Und wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
18 Jahre habe ich angefangen, das weiß ich noch.
Und jetzt vor 6 Jahren habe ich aufgehört.
Also sind das 38 Jahre?
Ja, 30 Jahre, okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol. Also ich trinke so am Abend dann 2-3 Leser Bier.
Täglich, oder?
Ja, eigentlich jeden Abend so.
Aber das ist nur für Sie, so ein weniger zu trinken.
Ja, man muss doch etwas trinken.
Zum Abendessen und dann noch so zum Abend, zum Fernsehen.
Ja.
Okay, wenn Sie Hilfe brauchen, können Sie mir sagen, also wir haben 1%...
Ach, 2-3 Leser Bier machen doch nix.
Okay, wenn Sie das sagen, kein Problem für mich.
Und Fraberge, bitte nehmen Sie diese Fragen nicht persönlich.
Also diese Frage muss ich für jede Patient fragen.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen probiert, oder konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Ich?
Nee, also nur wirklich nicht. Nein, nein.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Nein, das klappt nur wirklich gar nicht mehr.
Ich habe früher so viel gearbeitet, das war Sport genug.
Und jetzt geht es auch gar nicht mehr.
Okay.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwidert.
Verwidert.
Und haben Sie Kinder, Fraberge?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon groß, ne?
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
3 Kinder haben wir.
Tochter oder Zöhne?
3 Zöhne.
Sind Ihre Zöhne gesund oder?
Nein, der eine leider überhaupt nicht.
Der ist schwer pflegebedürftig.
Hatte einen schweren Motorradunfall, das ist auch meine große Sorge.
Und der ist eigentlich total auf Hilfe angewiesen,
aber er ist in einer Pflegeeinrichtung.
Ich betreue den also nicht regelmäßig.
Ja, ist das der Leitbrauber.
Sie sind, Sie beschäftigen als Hausmeister, oder?
Ja, ich bin jetzt schon in Frührente.
Ich hatte schon genug Arbeitsjahre drauf und dann habe ich aufgehört,
weil es mir eigentlich zu viel wurde.
Und hatten Ihre Eltern irgendeine Böse vor Erkrankungen oder chronische Erkrankungen?
Die sind beide im hohen Alter dann an Krebs gestorben.
Also, was die genau hatten, mein Vater hatte glaube ich Knochenkrebs
und aber das ist es auch schon Jahre her, dass der gestorben ist.
Und meine Mutter hatte auch irgendeine Tumorerkrankung
und ist dann im hohen Alter aber auch erst verstorben.
Es tut mir sehr leid, mein Beileid.
Haben Sie Geschwister Frau Berger?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Okay, Frau Berger, ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werden wir Ihnen einen Brut abnehmen.
Ich soll mit meinem Otto Berarts über Ihren Fall sprechen.
Ich werde Sie gleichzeitig darüber informieren.
Also, möchten Sie noch etwas fragen oder haben Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich glaube, Sie haben mir jetzt wirklich sehr viel erzählt.
Also, ich will natürlich wissen, was man jetzt dagegen tun kann.
Sie haben erst einmal sehr gut gemacht Frau Berger.
Also, Sie sind ja gekommen.
Ich werde Sie sehr gut betreuen, machen Sie keine Sorgen.
Okay.
Haben meine Kolleginnen oder Kollegen Fragen?
Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihre Beine angeschwollen sind.
Bitte Sie die Schwellung nach zurück.
Ja, morgens ist das noch nicht.
Und wenn ich im Laufe des Tages schwellen, die Beine an.
Frau Berger, Sie haben gesagt, Ihre Hausarzt,
eigentlich Sie haben einige Beschwerden bei Hausarzt.
Ja, welche Diagnose hatten Sie damals?
Ja, also, man hat mir vor einem halben Jahr gesagt, ich hätte Vorhoflemmen.
Deswegen habe ich das Makumar bekommen.
Und dann hat er jetzt gesagt, wenn ich wieder Schwierigkeiten habe,
wenn ich ihn nicht erreichen kann, soll ich gleich ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Frau Berger, haben Sie Herzstolpern oder Rasen?
Nee, also, das habe ich eigentlich nicht bemerkt.
Also, dass das ein bisschen, vielleicht, dass das so ein bisschen klopf im Hals merkt man manchmal.
Aber ein bisschen mehr als normal, wenn ich mich anstrenge.
Aber dass das stolpert, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Perfekt.
Leiden Sie beim Beschwerden von Kalte Schweiß oder haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nicht witzentrulich, eigentlich nicht besonders, nein.
Guten Abend, Frau Berger.
Ist Ihnen blau, lippen oder Finger aufgefallen?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Hatten Sie Markumar regelmäßig in den letzten drei Wochen regelmäßig angenommen?
Ich meine ja, dass ich das nie vergessen habe, ja.
Okay.
Sie haben diese Beschwerden durstgefühlt,
nur beim Belastung oder in Ruhe haben Sie keine Beschwerden?
Eigentlich eher nicht, nein.
Aber dann ist es eben mit einmal so, dass es mir Angst macht.
Und wenn ich jetzt ganz flach liegen würde, hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch die Beschwerden.
Deswegen schlafe ich mit erhöhtem Oberkörper.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Trotz Ruhe.
Können wir weiter machen?
Schauen wir aus.
Okay.
Hallo Frau Wischmann, ich habe eine neue Patient aufgenommen.
Haben Sie eine Zeit, oder?
Ich habe Zeit, ja.
Frau Helena Berge ist 64 Jahre Jahre, die sich heute Abend bei uns wegen
seit heute Nachmittag bestehenden Disziplinen mit engen Gehör vergestellt hat.
Außer dem Erwähnt, sie, dass sie an der Torakalschmerz leiden,
ohne Ausstrahlung.
ohne Ausstrahlung?
Ja, ohne Ausstrahlung.
Und die Patienten, die folgende Begleitung haben aufgefallen,
sie klagen über Trockenen, besonders morgen aufgetreten sei.
Und Abgeschlagenheit und geschwollene Füße,
beidseitig geschwollene Füße und Orthopne, also sie können nur mit 2
auf eine Nüchtheit und in Somnien.
Das weiteren Klagte Frau Berge über Gewichtsunahme von ca. 2-3 kg in den letzten 3 Monaten.
An Vorerkrankungen leide sie an eine Arterehipotonie und erhöhte Brutfettwerte
seit 10 Jahren und sie habe für sie eine Pankreatitis gehabt.
Es wurde bei ihr vor 10 Jahren eine Knitte durchgeführt,
in Bezu-Kafti Medikation, Nehme Frau Berge, Markuma, Halbtablette.
Warum nimmt sie Markuma?
Ich habe es nicht gefragt, aber während der kömpelischen Untersuchung werde ich fragen.
Sie haben Markuma wegen Vorhoffliman eingenommen.
Wann ist das aufgetreten?
Wie bitte?
Wann hat man das festgestellt, das Vorhoffliman?
Ich habe es nicht ganz gut gehört.
Vor 6 Monaten.
Ein Atowastatin, 20 mg noah abends, Bysoprol, 5 mg noah morgens,
Hydrochlorotheasit, 12,5 mg morgens, Isnopil, 10 mg noah morgens.
Sie haben es eingenommen.
Im Status sei es vollständig.
Bei der Reise an einem ist es keine Reise.
Sie haben eine Hausstauallergie, die mit Schnupfen und Augen tränen.
Haftbegriff für Schnupfen?
Ich habe es vergessen.
Wie ist es?
Er hat eine Amoxilinallergie, die mit Pruritus exantem oder exantem aushält.
Sie haben vor 6 Jahren mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Mit dem Rauchen aufgehört, das ist sehr gut.
Damals haben sie Seinsigaretten 38 Jahre lang geraubt.
Sie trinken täglich 2-3 Flasche Bier.
Geläser.
Sie haben keinen Kontakt, keinen Rogen.
Sie treiben keinen Sport.
Frau Berge ist verwidert und hat 3 Söhne.
Sie haben eine Unfall gehabt.
Sie haben eine Unfall gehabt?
Sie ist eine Hausmeisterin.
Sie war früher Hausmeisterin, aber jetzt in Rente.
Ihr Vater ist an Knorenkrebs gestorben.
Sie ist ein sehr Kind.
Aufgrund der erwähnten Symptome von einer Herzdyspitiensaus,
als Differenzialdiagnose, kommen die Folgenden im Betracht,
als eine Pofaka, Tifate oder Corona-Herzkrankheiten.
Als erstes würde ich diese Patient-Körpherlisch untersuchen.
Die EKG haben Sie schon gemacht?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe es schon gemacht.
Ich habe eine Folgen der Therapie-Massnahmen durchgeführt.
Also Labo und EKG.
Bei Labo würde ich BSG, Innere, Brutbild,
CKM, Metroponin und BMP untersuchen.
Ich habe schon einmal mein EKG verschrieben lassen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung besonders?
Ich habe es schon gemacht.
Ich habe eine Überwärmung, Schwellung, Schmerzen.
Wenn es möglich ist, würde ich eine Translösse,
eine Biografie und als Beine und Transsonne berechnen lassen.
Weil diese Patient vor 600 Jahren eine Vorfliege haben.
Es sollte kontrolliert werden.
Bei Bestätigung der Diagnose schlage ich die Folgen der Therapie vor.
Also eine gesundes Detailzung.
Die Patient sollte den Trinken aufgehört.
Sie sollte mit dem Trinken aufhören.
Sie sollte in Alkoholkonsum reduzieren.
Es ist eine echte Frage.
Trinkmenge einschränken oder kontrollieren.
Oder bringt es nichts?
Wir kontrollieren es normalerweise.
2-3 Glasabier.
Ich meine insgesamt Trinkmenge.
Also nicht Alkohol?
Flüssigkeit, Reduktion.
Trinkmenge einschränken.
2-3 Glasabier ist am Abend.
Das ist ein guter Liter.
Man trinkt es am Abend.
Man kann die Kopfsalzarme halt halten.
Wir können eine ACE-Inhibitöre,
oder eine Beta-Blocke, oder andere Diuretikum verschreiben.
Sie haben schon die Hydrocholeure, die es gibt.
Wir können diese Medikamente neu einstellen.
Neue oder feine Einstellung.
Die Diuretikum können wir verlassen.
Gut, ja.
Ich bin gespannt, dass bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Lassen Sie mich wissen, was Sie für Untersuchungsergebnisse haben.
Auch, wie die Laborwerte sind.
Dann schauen wir nachher nochmal zusammen nach der Patientin.
Sie waren ja super schnell.
Das ist mein Alkohol.
Mein Fall war eine Herzinsuffizie wegen der Cardiopatie.
Ich habe mit dem Zigaretten aufgehört.
Was mir aufgefallen ist,
sind sprachlich sehr souverän unterwegs.
Sie können mit der Sprache sehr gut umgehen.
Sie sind manchmal ein bisschen schnell.
Wenn Sie zum Beispiel die Medikamente aussprechen,
muss man schon wissen, worum es geht.
Sonst kann man sie nicht gut verstehen.
Lassen Sie sich da ruhig ein bisschen mehr Zeit.
Dass die Kollegen Sie verstehen.
Dass auch der Patient versteht, wovon Sie sprechen.
Sie müssen gar nicht so schnell sein.
Aber an sich wirkte das für mich alles sehr sicher.
Sie haben die Patientin immer schön mit Namen angesprochen.
Sie haben systematisch ihren Fragenkatalog abgefragt.
Sie haben eine komplette Wiedergabe gegeben.
In sehr kompakter Form.
Dass der Kollege wusste,
die Kollegen wusste, was ist mit der Patientin.
Ich wüsste da nicht viel daran zu kritisieren.
Wie gesagt, das Einzige, ein bisschen langsamer.
Ich habe am Abfall ein bisschen verwechselt.
Ich glaube, die Reiche.
Eigentlich war das alles okay.
Ich habe es auch schon gemacht.
Denken Sie daran, die Fachbegriffe zu nehmen im Arztgespräch.
Da habe ich zum Teil nachgefragt,
dass Sie das spontan die Fachbegriffe verwenden.
Das wäre vielleicht noch so ein Tipp.
Aber sonst kann man das nicht viel besser machen.
Vielen Dank, Frau.
Jetzt waren wir super schnell heute Abend.
Wir sehen uns wieder heute.
Wir sehen uns dann am Donnerstag.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen für heute einen schönen Abend.
Bis Donnerstag.
Tschüss.
Ich habe die die Verordene.